I went and gave a talk at this school
with it's a Christian School I'm giving
this message and the guy that talks
before me was the dean and he goes up
there and he says listen you know we we
have to be careful with the way we talk
about America because America has a
history and it's not perfect you know in
in at the same time we are doing our
best and there's a lot of things we have
to figure out and he's kind of almost
like apologizing about America so I get
up there and I say first of all I want
to thank you for giving me the stage
here to talk to these 600 kids in the
audience fantastic I said but let me
start off with one thing here everybody
needs to know America is the greatest
country in the world you see certain
people get uncomfortable let me say it
one more time never apologize about the
greatness of America and how it
positively impacted the entire world you
know what was wild I had no idea what
the reaction was going to be everybody
stood up these kids who are 12 13 14 15
16 17 years old want to love their
country right they want to be proud of
what they're representing right